A salt merchant took his ass to the seaside where he bought sacks of salt.
He loaded the sacks of salt on the ass and set off for home.
On the way home, they had to cross a river.
The ass slipped and fell into the river.
When the ass got to his feet,...
...he found his load was not so heavy because most of the salt had melted in the water.
The merchant now had to go back to the seaside and buy more salt.
This time, he bought more than before.
Once again, they came to the river on their way home.
This time, the ass made himself fall into the water...
...so that it would melt the salt in the sacks on his back.
The merchant saw what the ass had done...
...and was very angry with it for trying to cheat him.
He took it back to the seaside and filled the sacks with sponges instead of salt.
When they reached the river on their way home,...
...the ass again made himself fall into the water.
This time, however, the sponges became full of water...
...and the sacks were now heavier than before.